all right it's been a major week on my
Instagram account which clearly you were
following very very closely i'm on
instagram at david pakman a picture that
a lot of people liked that was me at
ring of fire studios in pensacola
florida over the weekend sitting uh in
the studio from which attorney Mike
Papantonio typically joins us when I
interview him and people liking it
people commenting that I seem very very
washed out people commenting that it
appears as though I've shaved my
typically incredibly hairy legs which of
course I didn't do it's just the
lighting in the picture but yeah it was
fascinating as I talked about on the
bonus show yesterday to see their setup
this is one of two studios that they
have there and people loving it and your
cross-legged here too you don't have
your feet up on the desk as you
sometimes do here so you're clearly not
as comfortable there oh no no no no here
I wasn't going to start a you know
leaning back and putting my feet up on
their desk that desk is arguably more
expensive than ours now that ours was
cheap we have a custom desk here that
actually did anyway this is not about
the desk specifically also people going
totally bonkers over a picture of ramen
noodle soup that I posted last night
this is actually much too vegan producer
Pat's chagrin because of the presence of
a soft-boiled egg in the soup this is a
vegan recipe to which I opted to add a
soft-boiled egg you could replicate this
recipe pad without the egg and it would
be a vegan recipe and it's absolutely
tremendous it's a it's a mushroom miso
broth okay and you know I don't know how
you feel about me so these days well
this isn't the Marshawn ramen that you
make in the microwave right this is a
step up from that is this is not instant
soup that you're absolutely right about
that and I would I would be interested
in putting you on record as to whether
you would commit to making this recipe
yeah without the hard-boiled egg yeah
you know I should start an Instagram
account and put up my lunch from writer
day which was a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich is that considered vegan these
days because well a lot of breads I just
want to warn you as a vegan I'm guessing
you know this if you look at the
ingredient
on certain loaves of bread there is
sometimes dehydrated milk or some kind
of dairy products in there you gotta to
gander at those ingredient guess you do
yes you do anyway follow me on instagram
David Pakman you will be able to see the
soup that without a soft-boiled egg
vegan producer Pat may one day make and
that will be I think it would actually
take away from the building
scandals that you have related to coffee
and fast food and all of that yeah a
nice soft hearted story would be good
for me and I think it could really do a
lot for your approval rating yeah